we can hear now from the ukrainian
president vladimir zelinski he's been
making daily uh video messages uh he's
just released another one let's listen
to it
i
wish victory to ukrainian people
that's what we hear from our friends
these words are important words of
support
but also backed up with specific actions
every evening i speak to the leaders of
international organizations in different
countries
and
last night i spoke to mr biden i'm
grateful to his determination
and new
list of decisions that
were made i also spoke to
you as congressman
and
people are
very frank and
they do want to help us
these conversations help our confidence
because if
there is light then we won't fall into
the darkness
we need to have this light
above our
land
we need to make sure that our sky is
safe i spoke to
prime minister of australia and i'm
grateful to their attitude to uh russian
import
these countries should not be able to
earn money
i'm grateful to israel for their support
for ukraine
we need
support of the countries
and
we were talking about
support we need now and how we're going
to cooperate in the future after the war
we need support from everywhere
and
if
the corporate world is supporting you as
well then you have even more
ways to fight this
evil
we are fighting for our today
we are fighting for our borders we are
fighting
for our freedom not to become slaves and
this is our choice but also the
nationals of russian federation are
making their choice as well
right now this is the time
when we can
overcome the evil when it's not too late
when you can only lose your job but not
go to gulag
it's not too late don't miss your
opportunity
colleagues
and
your relatives should
be able to hear you we are ukrainians
and we want peace
russian nationals this is the fight not
just for the peace in ukraine this is
the fight for your freedom
for
your life
if you stay silent now
then in the future only your poverty
will speak on your behalf don't be
silent
russian military
now talk to us those who were captured
hundreds of
russian soldiers and pilots who were
dropping bombs on our cities we heard
their evidence we saw documents
evidence
such as maps
and these are all pieces of evidence
this is not some improvised war it is a
deliberate deliberate pre-determined
intention
they
planned this war
we saw
the pure evil
that
came down on our
cities but
we follow the
convention
of the
geneva geneva convention when we deal
with the prisoners of war
every day
we
are being attacked from russia they use
their missiles their weapons
all our cities towns and villages are
being attacked
they're planning to bomb odessa
russian people always used to come to
odessa
and they always were welcome there and
what are we having now bombs against
odessa missiles against odessa this is
going to be
a criminal a crime international crime
we're fighting
for four for 11 days we've been fighting
now and we already start thinking about
rebuilding
our country
we are setting up funds for rebuilding
the
ruined infrastructure
we are setting up funds for
servicing and paying off debts
and we are developing more and more
programs to support
our soldiers and people who are fighting
for our country
now we need wisdom we need spirit we
need victory we need peace
peace to save ukraine